that are replaceable. Okay we're done so we will have you check the volume level
level and we're okay good. My name is Stephen Lawson it's September 19th
2011 and we are in a room in the Valley Library on the campus of Oregon State
University. So this is the second of our interviews that is basically doing one
quality and personal characteristics and we want to do a lot of different things
I'll ask when I want to start to say by talking about the Pauline family and the
interaction that you have with Pauline's children, you'd like to sell it here.
Peter Pauline, I believe I met Peter probably in the late 1970s or early
1980s for the first time when he was visiting his father or his parents in
California from England. Very interesting fellow he was in a way the black sheep
of the family in terms of his personal habits he seemed to drink quite a lot
and was a smoker so I think that some of those habits had some health
consequences for him late in life but he was a very personable very direct
person with a good sense of humor I really enjoyed my interactions with him.
In the early 1990s I received a box addressed to me at the Linus Pauline Institute
of Science and Medicine in Palo Alto, California with no return address and no
letter inside but the box held what appeared to be Linus Pauline's chemistry
Nobel Prize medal and I was very perplexed by this I didn't know why it would
be sent to me who sent it except that the postmark was Europe from Europe so I
knew that it originated in Europe but I had no understanding of who sent it or why
and whether or not the medal was authentic I called up Henry Talbe who's a
Nobel Prize winner in chemistry at Stanford who was a good friend of Linus
Pauline's and I compared the medals and the the medal that I had got in the
male seemed to be authentic except for the fact that it seemed to be an
alloy rather than solid gold or gold plated whatever the actual medal is I put
it aside in my office and about a week and a half or two weeks later I received
a second package from Europe again no return address no correspondence this
time there was the Nobel Peace Prize medal inside the box so now I was really
stumped and very curious as to why these were being sent to me and who had sent
them and about a week or two after that second box had arrived I received a
phone call from Peter who was in England at the time and he asked me early on
in the conversation if I'd received anything unusual in the mail recently and I
said well yes Peter I have I received two replicas of your father's Nobel
prizes and he said oh good I'm glad you got those he very graciously had gone
to the academies and had duplicate medals struck in an alloy for family members
and for the Linus Pauline Institute of Science and Medicine which I thought was
very nice of him and I think he had that done well it was around the time of
his father's death I don't recall if it was before or after but it was right
around that era when he did that I never really had a chance to talk to Peter
about his scientific work or his work in on chemical structure we did talk
occasionally about the vitamin C in cancer work that Pauline was doing in
collaboration with you and Cameron and Scott one and Peter was very interested in
that work of course although I don't know that he actually communicated much
with you and Cameron even though they wasn't the same island there off Europe
Linda Pauline I've known for quite a long time I think I met her either a party
at her parents house in Portola Valley or perhaps at the Linus Plain Institute
of Science and Medicine in Memo Park she's a very nice person like I said I've
known her for a very long time and I knew her husband I think perhaps before I
met her because her husband would visit the Linus Pauline Institute in Palo Alto
occasionally to talk with his father and law Linus Pauline because they had
jointly authored papers in theoretical physics and chemistry and Barkley was
a very interesting person and I remember asking him to explain one of the
papers to me that he co-authored with Linus Pauline and he said he was stumped by
it which is a very amusing I got to know Linda a little bit better when the
Linus Plain exhibition was being planned because we both served on the advisory
committee so we were meeting together with family members and other people from
the scientific community and Soka Gakai quite often to both plan the Linus
Plain exhibition and at the different venues at which you convened so I did get
to know her her pretty well and I remember when we moved files from the
Linus Plain Institute of Science and Medicine here to Oregon State University
many of the files from Pauline's office were moved to Wendell-Gurhal before
they were transferred to special collections and I was looking through some of
those files for one reason or another and I came across a letter from
Richard Feynman Nobel Prize winner at Caltech to Linus Pauline
apparently in response to a letter that Pauline had sent to him earlier because
the earlier letter was referenced in the response from Feynman to Pauline and
Feynman at that time had been diagnosed with an often fatal disease and I think
Linus Pauline had written to him suggesting that high dose vitamin C may have
some value and apparently in the earlier letter that Pauline sent to Feynman
he had enclosed some reprints of papers that he and Cameron had written on
vitamin C in cancer explaining host resistance and stimulation of the immune
system and so forth so Feynman had written back to Pauline thanking him for
providing all this information to him and mentioning that he was going to share
this with his physician and then I think in a separate paragraph he he started
an impair phrasing that he was been thinking about Pauline's long career
very productive career and all the major contributions that he had made to
science and humanity and he closed by saying something quite clever and
funny he said no Linus I'm thinking about all your achievements and the
wonderful things you've done for society but I think your greatest achievement
your greatest contribution has been your daughter Linda I thought that was quite
funny you recall any conversation he had with children and then reflecting back
on that dance at all talking about them and what was like to be at Pauline
not really I think when I was engaged with Crowlin Linda or Peter particularly we
were either in social settings in which there were a lot of people involved so it
wasn't easy to have a protracted conversation or they were meetings in which
we had specific strategic goals and we talked about various businesses or
relationships or so forth but I never asked any questions about family history of
any of the children actually even though I had many opportunities it just never
occurred to me to delve into their personal relationships with their parents
maybe I felt it was a little improper for me to do so
so Crowlin I had known Crowlin for quite a long time he came by the Institute
as did all the children from time to time so I would see them although I didn't
communicate much with him Crowlin became more active with the Institute as his
father's illness progressed and as we were struggling with future options for
the Institute and he was also the executor I believe of his father's will and
some of the elements of that will affected the Linus Piling Institute of Science
Medicine so one thing that I discussed with Crowlin in great detail and we
communicated about many times both Orlean and writing concern royalties to
some of Linus Piling's books because Pauline had written for instance how to
live longer and feel better as an employee of the Linus Piling Institute of
Science and Medicine and he had directed that out all royalties and revenue from
that book be given to the Linus Piling Institute and when it came time to tie up
some loose ends concerning the Linus Piling Institute of Science and Medicine I
was interested in whether that same principle would apply to some of Pauline's
other books in particular vitamin C in the common cold or vitamin C in
cancer which of course again was written as an employee of the Linus Piling
Institute of Science and Medicine so Crowlin and I discussed those issues
several times and he seemed to be very amenable to reason which I thought was
great
Linus Piling Jr. I enjoy Linus Piling
Jr. very much and of all the children I've worked most closely with him and I
think I probably know him best of all the children I had seen him from time to
time when he came to California to participate in trustees meetings because I
believe he's been on the Board of Trustees of the Linus Piling Institute of
Science and Medicine excuse me probably since its inception and periodic
board meetings were held over the years and I would see him but I never really
met him until the institute was reorganized in the early 1990s and there was a
desire I think on the part of the Board and on the part of Linus Piling
Jr. to spare his father from some of the administrative responsibilities and
tasks associated with running the Institute on a day-to-day basis and let him
concentrate on research which really is what he wanted to do and since time
was becoming more precious everyone felt that that's what he should do what he
wanted to do which was to focus on science so I talked with Linus Piling
Jr. after I was asked by the Board to become executive officer and then later
chief executive officer of the Linus Piling Institute of Science and Medicine and
Linus Jr. became chairman of the Board of Trustees he and I worked very closely
together for several years and communicated very often about financial
personnel management issues at the Institute in particular there was the
possibility that the former president director of the Institute I am Ylzukukondl
would start a new institute called the Institute of Medical Molecular Sciences
and that we would subly space in the building at 440 Page Mill Road to IMMMS and
that was a very complicated and somewhat controversial and divisive issue and
Linus Piling Jr. and Linus Piling had asked me along with a couple of the
people at the Linus Piling Institute of Science and Medicine to analyze this
possibility and report as to whether or not it would work practically and if
so how we would manage that that sublease and sharing of the physical space in
the building so I worked very closely with Linus Piling Jr. during that period and
then of course in trying to stabilize the finances of the Institute which
were always teetering in those days and worked with him closely on public
relations and kind of marketing of the Institute and later very closely on
trying to identify options for the future of the Institute because with
Linus Piling's demise and the problems that confronted us in Palo Alto was not
certain that the Linus Piling could carry on as a viable research organization
or even if that was the ideal option for the future. So we spent many hours
in days analyzing and debating what the right future for the Institute might be
and eventually decided that keeping the Orthon Molecular Medical Mission as a
lasting legacy to Linus Piling's work in Orthon Molecular Medicine which is why
the Institute was founded in the first place would be the most appropriate
future for the Institute so Linus Piling Jr. and I set about trying to identify as
I said options for relocation.
You mentioned Barclay Cam when they had their other people with other
extended Cam family or any other colleagues out there that you had contact with?
Yes. Barclay Cam's son, Barclay Cam Jr. I believe.
My column Barkey is a partner at Cooley Godward in Palo Alto and his wife was
asked to become a trustee of the Linus Piling Institute of Science and Medicine
back after the reorganization in the early 1990s and we had quite a few
onerous legal issues to deal with at the time and Barclay being part of that
law firm that we hired to provide legal counsel and advice was very helpful
to the Institute and I talked with him many times at that time and of course I
saw him socially as well.
I don't believe that I had much interaction with the other extended members of
the family. At about the time of Pauling's death before he died and after he died
there were of course many visits from extended families, Linus Piling Jr.'s
family, Linus family and others and I met many of the the grandchildren and
children and so forth but I can't say that I really had very meaningful conversations
with any of them.
You brought something up that I hadn't thought to ask about but it makes perfect sense to
it and I guess you had a pretty prospective on the transfer of point
and the members from the F.
He's in a lot of the work at the O.D. offices.
Yes.
Do you have any questions on your hand?
Yeah it was very interesting. I've always been in favor of transparency and
access and I thought that I've always thought that access to Pauling's papers and
memorabilia should be encouraged for scholarship because there's a lot to
learn there and I think the more people look into Pauling's career and activities
the more interesting and astonishing it becomes. It's really a multi-faceted
project although I didn't have some concerns initially about
when I learned that the intent of special collections which I think is a good
one was to make Pauling's papers available online.
It struck me as a really terrific project especially the scientific papers,
the research notebooks and so forth but I was concerned about the correspondence
being scanned and made available online for a couple of reasons.
One, many people would write to Pauling
with asking for advice on medical issues. They had cancer, they had various
disease, they had a friend or relative or a colleague with disease and they
wanted to know how much vitamin C to take or what other therapies might be
appropriate to treat this particular disease and sometimes they would include
a donation and typically the way these donations were processed the
photocopy of the check might be made and then stapled some of the
correspondence. So I was concerned that there needed to be some
judicious oversight in the way material was scanned and made available online
because medical conditions confidential medical and financial information
related to some of Pauling's correspondence. I didn't feel it should be released
to the public so I was a little hesitant in
making that material available to Oregon State University until special
collections had come up with some sort of strategy to screen that material to
protect those confidential issues of people that had written to Pauling over
the years and never suspected that their letters or
information would be publicly available on the internet.
Partly because the internet hadn't existed when they wrote and
for other reasons. Many of Pauling's
files, his manuscripts, a lot of the scientific work, his correspondence were
maintained by Dorothy and Monroe at the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and
Medicine. So of course those files were under our control for many years and
then I worked with you and with Cliff Mead as well who was a director of special
collections at that time to ensure that that this material got transferred to
special collections. Although in many cases everything was moved
in one project by a moving company from the 440 Page Mill
road address in Palo Alto to the campus of Oregon State University and to
simplify things almost everything in that move went to our area and went
into our hall and was stored in various rooms and then from time to time those
files and filing cabinets and materials were then transferred to special
collections. I'm interested in and I think they're about
the chalkboard. Do you have memories of falling piece of that board and then now
how would you store it? I do have some memories of that. The green board that was
in his office, he seldom erased from it. Sometimes he inadvertently erased
things because he would move too closely or a guest in the office would move too
closely to the board and their their code or shirt would inadvertently erase
some of the writing on the board. I once asked Dorothy Monroe maybe out of
vanity why my name wasn't on the board because I noticed that the names of
some of the institute employees were on the board and I was curious as to why
my name wasn't and he said well that's because he knows you so well. He
doesn't need to have your name on the board as a monomic device because
sometimes for people that he didn't interact with regularly to associate the
name on the board with the person when they came into his office was very
useful to him and the entrance to his office was adjacent to that green board so
it could very easily look from the person to the board and back and and attach
the name to the to the person that was standing in front of him if he was
unclear as to who that person might be. I think Cliff Mead the former director of
Special Collections managed the technical aspects of moving the chalk board. I
know that there were issues about electrostatic
disilligment of the chalk particles from the board if different types of acrylic were used and
there was discussion about spraying the board with some sort of sealant that would forever
fix the chalk to the board but whatever technique was used and I believe a box was
built around the board and it was moved very carefully they didn't have
standing job because as far as I can tell there was no loss of information and
when the board was moved from Pong's office to special collections.
Something else getting away from calling a little bit here but something else
that you referenced that I wanted to about it to travel into the New York window and
it's the SGI exhibit. Yeah. Well I think that the origin for that exhibit probably goes back to
I know Dasaka Akeda the head of SGI in line is pulling head met in
conversed prior to the establishment of the Linus Plain Expression so they were acquaintances and
I think SGI or Akeda had expressed a desire to do something for Linus Pong or the Linus
Plain Institute of Science and Medicine and I think although I'm not exactly clear on this my
recollection I hadn't thought about this in a while and I hadn't consulted any files but I think
that the I think that desire was transformed into the exhibition partly due to conversations
perhaps with Linus Pong Jr. in the early 1990s and then of course we thought it would be a way
of educating the public about this extraordinary man and introducing school children to Linus Pong
as a role model perhaps because Linus Pong worked in chemistry and chemistry is not
that sexy as subject to many citizens in the United States cosmology theoretical physics things
like that things that Einstein was involved in or Carl Sagan was involved and seemed to resonate
with people but chemistry is a little bit difficult a little bit oblique to many people so
we thought that having an exhibition devoted to Linus Pong and all facets of his career as a
humanitarian as an activist as a scientist as a medical researcher would be a way of honoring
Linus Pong his legacy and also introducing his incredible work to school children and people
around the world it was hugely successful millions of people saw it in locations in Europe and Japan
and many locations in the United States it was terrifically well executed and designed very
very diligent and creative design people working with Soka Gakai transformed the exhibit or designed
the exhibit to fit into the available spaces in DC and San Francisco and Boston and everyone who
who saw the exhibit really thought it was very very impressive and actually Soka Gakai
when the exhibit had finished touring gave all the elements of the Linus Pong exhibition to Oregon State
University. Okay you seem very deploying a little bit I'm wondering if you ever go to Dear Flat Ranch?
I did I went down to Dear Flat Ranch they had a little guest house that was built I think at the
south end of the beach adjacent to the main house and I went down fairly late in Pauling's life I
think it must have been around 1993 perhaps even 1994 when I went there and my visit was associated
with a deposition that our attorneys were doing of Linus Pong related to litigation with health
now in Matthias Rat and I remember driving down and taking him the Sunday paper because I know
that he always liked to read the Sunday San Francisco Chronicle and the funny so I took him that
large paper and visited him at Dear Flat Ranch and got to see the house and wandered around the
beach and it was very very enjoyable and it was a little sad too because it was difficult to see him
somewhat incapacitated but it was really a terrific experience to be there. So I'm trying to get a
sense of the space here and it was very important for me to find.
And it was easy to see why it was so important to him because it was very remote and secluded.
There were no distractions a terrific natural environment in a house perched on a bluff over
looking the ocean very tranquil space and I think it's easy to see how we got a lot done there
without any internet connection or fax. I believe it might have installed a fax machine later on but
I was an ideal place for him to work and think without distractions because when he was in Palo Alto
he was a very famous man and his time was sought by many people for many different reasons. Old
friends, colleagues, the public, the media and I think it was difficult for him to concentrate at his
office at the Linus Plain Institute of Science and Medicine at least on Page Mill Road because
there were so many demands on his time when he retreated to dear flat ranch. He removed himself from
that contact, that connection so he was I think he really loved that time alone down there.
I believe the property is still owned by the family but I'm not exactly sure what they intend to do with it.
You don't have a good sense of what only gives the fun and the ideas on that regard.
Well I know that he'd like to watch some programs on TV, some serialized programs. He read quite a lot.
He loved to read mystery books and I think we may have talked about that in our earlier conversation.
I would loan him mystery books and he would loan me books and actually a lot of his books
before he died ended up at a bookstore in California Avenue in Palo Alto because he would stop in
that bookstore and trade books. It was a bookstore where you could trade or sell your used books for
books that they had in stock. So I remember looking through the bookstore and finding Linus Plain's
name and many of the books, the mystery and science fiction area that he had brought into trade for
other books that he was interested in reading. He didn't seem to have much interest in cinema,
in plays, in show business arts, fine art, music. I didn't seem to be anything that came up
very often in conversation so he did not really seek out those kinds of experiences. I think he
was happiest just doing his own work thinking about scientific problems. The few times that I
had cocktails with him and as a partner at Stanford, he was happy to sit and talk about a wide range
of things and he liked to drink vodka and we would typically have vodka and tonic. Sometimes he
would just drink straight up vodka or maybe with water and talk about a wide range of subjects. But
popular culture, the arts were really not, I don't think, of great interest to him. So he was a
rare individual in that there was really no division between, in my mind, what he did recreationally
and what he did professionally. I mean he was a scientist through and through and derived pleasure
from working on scientific problems and that pleasure I don't think was to be substituted for
pleasure and other activities. I'm sure that he did a lot of things on his own or with his wife
traveling and so forth and visiting different places with his wife that were enjoyable to him but
when I knew him best, late in life after his wife had died, it didn't seem that he was that engaged
in activities other than science. Okay, well I have a little list of personality characteristics that
are often assigned to calling out and looking at the reflectance and the first to be his work ethic.
Oh he was very industrious, very industrious. He worked all the time. As a matter of fact,
I remember going to parties that has some portola valley and using the restroom, the bathroom.
And oftentimes if you go into someone's bathroom you'll find a prevention magazine,
a reader's digest or entertainment weekly or time or the newspaper or something and Pauling's
bathroom was stack of journals, scientific journals.
Creativity? Well I think it goes without saying that he was extraordinarily creative and had an
interesting way of visualizing and thinking about scientific problems and issues so I think in
terms of creativity I can't think that at least in the scientific realm that he's surpassed by
anyone really. When you think about the nature of his stunning contributions to molecular medicine,
molecular biology, chemical bond, I don't think it gets much more creative than that.
And many people talk about his memory. His memory was prodigious. It's rare that you encounter
someone who has such a clear memory of so many details and Pauling was very frequently able to
recite the co-authors of papers that had been published, not just his own papers, but other papers
that had been published 30, 40 years earlier in the date and the journal and basically could give
you an abstract of that particular paper. So he had an incredible memory and I think that is
one of the reasons he was able to make so much progress in science. He was able to conjure facts
from deep in his memory about perhaps unrelated topics and fit them together in a real synergistic way
and make new discoveries. But I have felt my father also had a stunning memory. I won't say it was
photographic but it was close to being photographic. He was able, laid in life to remember things that
he had learned as an undergraduate at Massachusetts Institute of Technology that I found very surprising.
I would try to stump him with calculus problems when he was a businessman and he was not stop not
stumpable and Pauling was very similar, perhaps even better than my father on the memory score.
Well I think Linus Pauling had a healthy ego. I think he was well aware of his abilities.
Some people I think misinterpret that confidence in his own abilities as arrogance and I never
really interpreted that way. It seemed to me that he knew what he was talking about. He was able to
justify his opinion or his statements about various issues which he was talking and I think he
had a very healthy ego. Did you ever see him angry? Let's see. I'm not sure that I ever saw him angry.
I saw him when he was less than happy but I'm not sure that that would qualify as angry.
I've seen him concerned and maybe sad but not really angry. Although I'm sure he could,
for instance during the Mayo Clinic in Brolio in the late 1970s and mid 1980s he had every right to be very angry
and perhaps he expressed his anger to some of the participants in that controversy but I never saw him angry.
He tended to move somewhat slowly. Sometimes that was because he was carrying a heavy box with him
with correspondence and books and papers. So he never really seemed to be fatigued. He wasn't
physically vigorous. At the time I knew him at the Linus Point Institute of Science and Medicine but
he certainly didn't seem fatigued but he was not physically dynamic person.
How did he handle disappointment? There were a lot of grand applications between the
Molyton and the Times Institute and the Funded University of New York University.
Yeah I think he was disappointed clearly and all the emotions that go along would be
disappointed but he never felt dejected because I think he felt that he knew better than many of
the people who were denying him the grant funds and knew what was required to participate in the
grant funding game and was playing it and he was disappointed that he wasn't rewarded by playing
the game appropriately and the way he'd been told to play it by the funding agencies. So he was
somewhat chagrin that he couldn't get the money from federal agencies to do the kind of research
that he felt was very important. I didn't see him angry at particular people but he was unhappy
that he couldn't get financial support to do work that he felt would be very important in public
health. For instance the Vitamin C in Cancer work is a case in point. When Cameron had started
treating terminal cancer patients hospitalized waiting to die with high dose intravenous and
oral Vitamin C and reported to Pauline that some of these people were having very dramatic responses.
Pauline and Cameron collected a lot of the data pathology, histology, x-rays, so forth
and Pauline felt that that data was probably persuasive enough to get the National Cancer Institute
to set up randomized placebo-controlled double-blind clinical trial to test the efficacy of Vitamin
C in Cancer. Learn more about it and the reception he got by the NCI was very negative and they always
found a reason that maybe Vitamin C wasn't responsible for this response. Maybe it was coincident
with something else and Pauline said well that's exactly why I want these clinical trials to be
carried out to find out whether this has value and it totally we have evidence that has value.
Now we need to find out whether it does truly have value and NCI had sort of an odd perspective
on the problem. They wanted Pauline to apply for funds to study this in cell cultures and animals,
animal models like mice or rats. So Cameron already had some clinical evidence but they wanted to
turn the wheelbarrow upside down and start with cell cultures and animals so typically the trajectory,
the normal scientific trajectory would be to establish biological plausibility and see effects
in cell culture models and then move on into animal models to find out if you can replicate the
in vitro results in an in vivo model and then if that's all promising then you move eventually
into a clinical translation of this of this modality. And Pauline and Cameron were actually
starting at the end of that tripartate paradigm and he wasn't anxious to go back and start with
cell cultures and animals. So it was I think I'm sorry a bit frustrating to him and to
line to you and Cameron that they were reinforced to to start at the beginning when they already had
results in people that seemed to be very promising and they believed would be sufficient to set up
a randomized clinical trial to test this in people. Were you at all privy to or involved or
observed to Robert Perrydowke's collaboration with Pauline in development of the medical biodegrad?
Well Robert Perrydowke of course visited the institute many times because he was Pauline's
official biographer. So he came to talk with Pauline, talk with Dorothy Monroe, talk with people
calling colleagues at the institute and elsewhere many many times over the years and I got to know
him reasonably well. I never had much input there. I believe I may have spoken to him in the 1990s
about some of the litigation and Robinson and Rath issues.
I really don't know the status of the biography. I have no idea.
I wish a grin to learn at one point that he had no book contract and it seems to me that if
you have a book contract and that implies a deadline and you've got to you've got to have a
product by a certain date that the publisher is interested in producing and I was surprised to
find that apparently Robert Perrydowke never had a book contract and was doing this presumably
in hopes of shopping and around to different publishers at some later date but I think a book
contract would have really been a terrific catalyst to getting that project completed.
Tom Hager I talked with him and I like his book very much actually. I think it's probably the
best biography of Linus Pauline and Tom of course had some access to Pauline,
Lateness career and visited the institute several times and I was interested in I thought that the
last chapter in the end of the book to coincide with the end of Pauline's life was perhaps a
little bit abrupt and it was interested in working with Tom to develop that a little bit more
thoroughly especially with respect to the Rath litigation but I think the publisher was interested in
getting the book on the shelves, excuse me not long after Linus Pauline's death in August of 1994
and I think the book appeared in the fall of 1994 so I think that they were interested in wrapping
it up and getting it out there to sell while Pauline was still in recent memory in the news
because that would have been a good marketing opportunity for them and I have since talked with Tom
although I don't know if he has any desire to do this or is publisher as any desire to do this
in perhaps a new edition of this book which would wrap up some of the loose ends that were left
dangling in the original book. No I didn't know that. Not very interesting.
No, no I never had any contact as far as I can remember with Seraphini or the Gertzels.
I read their books, I thought they were interesting I mean I think no book is perfect and all have some
failures or defects and I think those two books have their share of failures and defects but
um what if Pauline used no media in here in France?
Well I think Pauline as a result of his campaign to end atmospheric testing on nuclear weapons
and his political activities in the 1950s, learned pretty well how to use the media and
I was struck by his facility with the media. I mean he gave hundreds or thousands of interviews
to journalists and media representatives throughout his life and he knew what the audience was
and he knew what part of the story to give to the particular interviewer for that particular
audience and he was extremely good at describing pretty complex scientific phenomena in ways that
perhaps the average intelligent person can understand and grasp them. So he was a terrific speaker
and was able to distill pretty complicated ideas down to easily digestible um communications.
Could the institute see I mean were there an institute that you remember were falling
gave it and in a view in a major publication it means to sign a pretty quick windfall from that.
Oh what? A pretty quick windfall or a bump in the amount of correspondence you received in that?
Yeah that's interesting well of course during the male clinic in Broly-O there was quite a lot of
communication between the public and the institute and Linus Pauling because at that time
although Cameron and Pauling pointed out that Craig and Martell who organized and carried out
that male clinic those male clinic studies two of which were published had not really read
Cameron or Pauling's papers and were not prepared to reproduce Cameron's work technically.
So they never gave any vitamin C intravenous land there were other problems with male clinic
studies that have been dealt with at length by other people.
So when people heard that the famous male clinic had apparently objectively evaluated
high dose vitamin C in cancer and came up with negative findings there was kind of a flood of
questions about this and Pauling and Cameron had prepared criticisms of the male clinic studies
and those were provided to people who were interested. I think that the only I can't remember
exactly big windfalls financial windfalls to the institute from the direct male program as a
result of public statements by Linus Pauling or other people at the Linus Plains Institute of
Science and Medicine but I do remember that there were negative consequences from both the male
clinic studies and somewhat later when people discovered that the institute was doing work on HIV
not AIDS but HIV infection, cell culture work and the effect of vitamin C in inhibiting replication
of the virus responsible for AIDS there were people that had moral problems with that work for whatever
reason and some donations dropped off as a result of that.
What do you hear the sense of Pauling's attitude towards the money especially in his
middle of life? Well, he's an assembly user pretty well the guy that is later used to do that.
Yeah I don't think money was an issue for him at least during the time I knew him on the latter
or third of his life. I feel fairly confident in saying that he didn't have any personal money
problems. He loaned money to the institute many times, directed royalties from books to come to
the institute so if he had needed money personally I don't think he would have done that for instance.
So to me he seemed like a very generous person financially. He was giving money to the institute,
he was trying to find money for the institute to carry out research that he felt was important.
So he seemed to be very generous and altruistic. He never seemed to be interested in
doing anything that would raise money for him. For instance the patents that he was involved
in acquiring weight in life, one in superconductivity and then patents related to lipo protein A and
vitamin C. I think the goal there was not to enrich himself but to find more revenue streams for
the institute so that it could do research that he felt was important. So I would say that's
very philanthropic attitude, very altruistic.
Did you have a travel inform? Let's see.
No, I guess I didn't. I traveled with him to City Hall in Palo Alto from his apartment and I
would often chauffeur him from his apartment at Stanford campus to the Linus Poly Institute
and take him home in the evening mainly because although his driver's license was still valid he
had decided not to drive so much anymore and it gave me an opportunity to talk with him about
scientific issues and administrative issues and he could regale me with stories from his past and
kind of a distraction free environment namely in the car while I was driving so but that's the
extent of my travel with him, local travel. Well in the early 90s he developed the illness that
would eventually take a while to try to treat up with an experimental treatment.
You know what you thought about that? Well when he went public with the diagnosis of prostate cancer
of course many people were shocked especially as critics. They weren't shocked I think they were
well I don't want to be too too critical of them but many people said we've been advocating
vitamin C for all these years and taking vitamin C for all these years and now you've got cancer
how do you explain that? And probably had a very rational non-defensive response which was
most elderly men develop hyperplastic or hyperplasia in their prostate most elderly men at autopsy
are found to have cancerous cells in their prostate and it's just not uncommon it happens to many
many elderly men and he said it's quite likely although not provable and I'm paraphrasing
that his high intake of vitamin C delayed the inevitable by 20 years and more because he died
at the age of 93 and a half and of course many men start to develop prostate problems 20 years
earlier than that so it's not a provable assertion but I think it's just as reasonable as any
other assertion about the relationship of vitamin C to his cancer. He treated himself both with
high dose vitamin C although I believe he did not take intravenous vitamin C perhaps just oral
vitamin C which is a little surprising but on the other hand the pharmacokinetics of vitamin C had
not been really clearly worked out and this was before the vitamin C transporters had been discovered
so no one really knew exactly how vitamin C got from the gastrointestinal track into the blood
stream into cells and tissues. It's clear that not all of it got into the blood stream from a large
ingested dose. Some was excreted, some that got absorbed was excreted and some just passed through
the intestinal track so the the pharmacokinetics were not well understood and it wasn't until after
applying died that that people started to to look into that more carefully and we now know for
instance that there are active transport molecules on cells in the intestine that limit the amount
of vitamin C that gets taken up by cells and moved from intestine into the blood stream. So when you
take large oral doses you cannot get the same blood concentration of vitamin C that you can get when
you get it intravenously because then you bypass these transporters on cells and get the vitamin C
directly into the blood stream. And some work actually a lot of work suggests that one of the major
anti-cancer mechanisms of high dose vitamin C is the generation of hydrogen peroxide as a result of
either auto-oxidation of vitamin C or reactions of vitamin C with metals and this seems to be selective
to tumor cells and hydrogen peroxide diffuses into the tumor cells and disrupts their cellular
machinery by different mechanisms. That wasn't really well known when Pauline was self-medicating with
vitamin C for his prostate cancer so he didn't prefer intravenous vitamin C at that point because
it wasn't any perhaps clear rationale for it. I know that he had surgery, he underwent a bilateral
orchiectomy and also was taken flutamide which is a standard chemotherapy drug for prostate cancer
and I know that he was also working with friends and colleagues at Stanford Medical School to raise
monoclonal antibodies against his prostate cancer cells and I don't really know
how those things work sequentially or whether he was combining some of those modalities. I'm not
clear about that but I know that all those avenues were tried by him
and he was actually quite public about his treatment and about his illness.
But if you recall the last time you saw him, I guess not.
I believe the last time I saw him was when he was deposed by our lawyers in 1994.
I think it was early summer, late spring or early summer of 1994 at his home in dear flat ranch.
What is your, what is your, what are your, that makes a fist meal?
Well, it's tough to have clear memories of such an emotional event.
Lannis Pauling was an unusual public figure and that many people who didn't even know him felt
very strongly about him either positively or in some cases negatively perhaps and people who knew him
really tended to love him because he was such a charming, magnanimous and wonderful person to be
around and when he died I think everybody that knew him was grief-stricken myself included and it
was very difficult. I was asked to speak at that funeral as was the president of Stanford University
Gerhard Kasper and a number of other people and it was very difficult to maintain composure and talk
about why Lannis Pauling at that event. What was the follow-up of his death experience?
Well, the immediate follow-up was probably a rise in memorial contributions in honor of Lannis Pauling.
We were of course very concerned about the long-term success of the Lannis Pauling Institute
because many people who had contributed money believed rightly so in many cases that Lannis
Pauling was at the helm of the ship and he was directing the research and he was director of
research at the end of his life and we were concerned that absent Lannis Pauling people might
start to lose interest in the Lannis Pauling Institute and stop supporting it financially and we
had no endowment at the time and we had some zoning problems with the building in Palo Alto. We were
in a least building on a commercially-zoned site in 440 Page Mail Road which was scheduled to change
residential zoning. So we knew we had to move and absent Lannis Pauling, no endowment and moving
was quite a challenge for the Institute and I alluded to this earlier the Board of Trustees
Lannis Pauling Jr. and myself really grappled for a long time with these issues thinking about
different opportunities and options for relocation and ultimately decided to come to an academic
institution because academic institutions except for a few tend to be permanent and we started
to look at academic institutions that were doing work that was compatible with Lannis Pauling
Institute of Science and Medicine's mission where this work in orthomolecular medicine would
find a good home and be able to be carried out as a working tribute to Lannis Pauling's ideas in
orthomolecular medicine. Very lucky for us during those deliberations we were the happy
recipients of a number of large bequest and those bequest allowed us to establish at least a small
endowment I shouldn't say endowment but to have enough money to fund an endowment for the
director's chair here at the Lannis Pauling Institute at Oregon State University which at that time
was matched by the state so it was a functional $3 million endowment which allowed us to attract
very high caliber director and subsequently with the help of the Research Office at Oregon State
University we were able to attract high caliber faculty as well so.
Well that's the end of my set of questions on the point I guess I'll just ask you if there's anything
else about polyproportality or personal characteristics or the relationship that you share that you're
interested in anything that is needed. Well I think I've said before I found him to be very funny
he was he was very charming very witty of course seemed to know everyone know everything
he was just a joy to be around and maybe I mentioned in our last interview that when Zellacermin
and I had finally succeeded in producing some material in a superconductivity project that
we all thought would exhibit a higher superconductive temperature to see the expression of
delight on Pauling's face when we showed him the material that we produced was
extremely memorable I have vivid memories of that because he was just as gleeful as a teenager
on a first date to show him that material and he just had a real joy for scientific discovery
and I think that was the the thing that most motivated him in life.